MICHEL DEGRAFF: From
the very beginning
of this course is designed
for this semester,
we wanted to connect the
humanities, the classroom,
with social justice.
And luckily, we
had guest speakers
who themselves have been
engaged in social change.
So for example, I mentioned
before John Turman.
There was also
Professor Fox Harrell.
In fact, most of
our guest speakers
have been engaged in real
life trying to make change
for social justice.
And because some of our
students were themselves
children of immigrants,
many of them
got very interested,
for example,
in the issue of migration.
Or to protect the
rights of migrants
who had been under attack in
the recent couple of years.
Thanks to John Turman,
some of the students
connected to the
MIRA group, which
is the Massachusetts Immigrant
and Refugee Advocacy coalition.
And they were actually
very happy to do so,
to be able to connect not
only the personal biographies,
but also the classroom
work with actual action
for social change.
And we also got to
understand the ways in which
what we are studying
in this course--
for example, the issue of
language and assimilation--
have impacts, say,
in the courtroom.
So the issue of language
and assimilation
was particularly evident in the
court case of George Zimmerman.
The trial of--
Zimmerman was accused of
killing Trayvon Martin.
This young black boy who
was seen in his neighborhood
after seeing his
dad and he was--
after he bought some
Skittles and some drinks
and he was killed
by this vigilante.
And the reason why
he was acquitted
is because the star witness
for the prosecution, Rachel
Jeantel, who happened to be
this young woman of Haitian
and Dominican decent, and
because of the way she spoke,
she spoke with a black accent.
And that accent,
undermined her credibility.
In fact, some of the
jurors were clear
that they would not believe
her because she sounded--
because of the way she spoke.
And there's a beautiful
analysis of this episode--
a very sad episode--
by John Rickford
and Sharese King in the
journal, the journal Language,
where they showed
very clearly that that
was the main factor
for Rachel Jeantel
to not be believed by the jury.
So here this is a
clear case where
attitudes towards language have
an impact on social justice.